I have kind of a direction question I
have hit on a video topic that just goes
so well it's very specific though and
I'm like do I make a new channel do I
make a new playlist like what do you do
when one of your topics kind of blows
the others out of the water I would make
it a series playlists are fine but think
more series and most people don't
consume by playlists so it's nice that
on your home page I have some playlists
for people to be able to ah she did it
upload some pop-up loads let's go Anna
we love it yeah and start here best of
the fairies this could be better than
best of the fairy but you could have it
here on your playlist that's fine if
they sign up and they just find this
picture maybe this is too new maybe they
just got this one right they just
watched this video
and you're talking about relationships
they want to see more content on
relationships and you might pull them
into your other stuff as well because
they probably have some kind of PTSD too
right this is the hero content that gets
you known but then not everybody but a
good chunk will follow into the next
thing that you want to promote in the
other videos as well so I would look at
doing a series on this so I don't know
you know how much you want to be making
content but ideally it's once a week
you're making this and once a week
you're doing the other stuff yeah I've
been doing three it's killing me
but it's good
well so what are the three like what are
the main themes of the three so the the
the the thought leadership one is one
that's scripted and that easily can be
adapted to a blog post and a bunch of
social media okay
um and then the other two I'm answering
a letter and it's improvised so it's a
lot more work if I were to try to
convert it into written form
but it works well that's something I
learned early on in this program was
just go ahead and improvise and so I I
people I get I don't know 100 letters a
day and I pick a couple and do every
week and do those
so I I do a strong opinion introduction
then I read the letter then I go back
over the letter and kind of go through
the little things they said and that's
what those ones are letters it's a
winning format yeah yeah and I have done
the letters for all kinds of things that
people write about but these ones about
obsessive romance are just hitting a
nerve and So lately in the other you
know I do these group coaching calls and
people come in I'm getting 700 lead
magnet leads a day
and you know sales go up some but
they're they're really coming into the
into the funnel here and then when I'm
on the call I do these free calls every
two two weeks on zoom and they're coming
in and saying oh yeah I saw your con
your video about obsessive romance and
that's me and I'm I just think oh this
is you know if I chose to that could
really make this the main business line
this would be the money maker I think
but my thought leadership in the general
area of complex PTSD is important to me
too
so if I'm if I'm looking at these you
have three series you've got the letters
you've got the thought leadership and
what's the third one there's no third oh
so how are you making three videos then
I do two letters oh two letters okay so
then the letters are easier for you to
make than the other ones yeah kind of
yeah
they're more on the back end for editing
and all that but
and are you editing or you're no no and
are you turning it into text for the
blog or no just starting now no okay so
then so then we're not as concerned
right all right right if it's more work
to turn it into a blog post but less
work for you like more work for team but
less work for you
yeah
then we win then we win
so I I like it I think if you had so if
you had two letters
per week just make one of the letters on
this theme
well I'm already doing two
two on the same theme
yeah well the obsessive love you could
talk about until the cows come home I
get I literally get a hundred letters a
day on it so I can do a lot of letters
on it
and it's driving now you know I went I
when I was doing two I went I just
started doing this topic twice a week
and I went to a thousand Subs a day yeah
wow so it's fun to go for the numbers
like the numbers themselves are pretty
rewarding but it's all it it kind of
turns into a new Direction
well as long as it still relates to
yeah the overall thing which yeah which
it does I just I would have it as a a
playlist
yeah a a theme that every week you're
adding at least one video but you're
still doing the other stuff as well yeah
all right well that's where I am now
still you learn so much by just doing it
you kind of learn what people respond to
yeah I mean this is like you get an idea
you you throw it against the wall and
see what happens yeah maybe you keep
doing it maybe not like if the letters
are
like what was your last thought
leadership piece here uh dumb advice you
should ignore
dumb advice yeah it's the fourth one in
there oh here's okay yeah but look at
that number 13 000 and eight days it's
the lowest performer
and this is the most work because it's
all scripted right yeah it's also the
shortest 12 minutes versus 30 26 42
that's partly why like your short ones
the script this is a scripted one too
[Music]
um
no no how about this one C cptsd
actually maybe it is yeah uh groups
trigger you that's scripted yeah the
shorter ones that's right the shorter
ones yeah I mean the shorter
they take the most work and they're
getting the least results yeah so okay
so why do we keep doing them one because
they're just a heck of a lot of fun for
you to do
block out
my silly
[Music]
it's all I've got them all I've got now
all my all my thought leadership videos
are indexed and and uh I can pull on
them for you know con for the book so
there's that but that's all I used to do
I started doing these letters at your
suggestion and at first it wasn't
successful
but I learned a couple of things in the
formula that make it really successful
which is really strong opinion and then
the thumbnail needs to be Sensational in
the in every sense of the word I had to
get a little more daring with how I
phrase things because I'm trying to be I
don't know I yeah when you're talking
about people cheating on their spouses
and stuff you know if I was putting a
more like thoughtful like you know being
faithful why it's important or something
instead you go cheat yay or nay you know
and that gets the clicks and yeah and
then it's the same video
yeah
yeah but I mean it could change the
intro
your powerful opinion yeah beginning
that's the single most important thing
I've changed since being in this
group
that totally changed everything was the
powerful opinion the opening yeah
Breaking the Habit I had from working in
public health of being circumspect and
not being too opinionated and just
getting in there and going you are
screwing up and here's what you need to
do
it works you gotta hold it works it
works and and and yeah I was always
afraid about what the therapists and
officials out there would think but I
got so many fans
and they're just like yeah right on I
give these to my patients
they can't really be that direct I can
solo videos
the most important thing is to lead with
a powerful opinion
and the question I always ask people is
what do you believe that others don't
so you're gonna make a video on habits
great what do you believe about habits
that other people don't that they would
find weird like I can't believe you said
that
because this is our goal is to hook
somebody in
this is specific for Thought leadership
videos you are a thought leader you are
an expert you know things that other
people don't know that's the whole idea
why am I watching you because you're
going to teach me something so what do
you believe that I don't already know
and that's the first thing that comes
out of your mouth
so you know I've done when I've done my
thought Leadership Academy we'll spend
half a day just working on this stuff
practicing it like writing it down and
then saying it to the camera because
it's really hard
a lot of times it's hard to get out of
our own heads and so imagine what I find
helpful is imagining somebody imagine
one of your clients so Stephen might
imagine an entrepreneur Robert or his
wife might be imagining somebody who's
you know dealing with trauma like you
picture somebody
and then that's the first thing you're
talking to this person
I would always picture this photographer
friend that I knew who always seemed to
struggle could never seem to figure it
out and instead of talking to the camera
like I'm talking to I'm talking to this
guy I'm talking to you
how would he react
um when I had my cameraman uh there was
one of them that uh
always seemed to kind of disagree with
what I said
at the beginning and it's like great
you're perfect so I pitched my first
sentence to him and then I see what his
reaction was and then that would that
would change how it would then pitch my
next sentence right it was like wait
what like perfect they got my first
sentence if you agree with me it's like
okay no I gotta I gotta I gotta change
it up so lead with a powerful opinion
the first thing out of your mouth this
is really hard because again A lot of
times people click record and then they
go back the default to how they've done
it hey welcome back it's Evan like no I
just told you don't do that powerful
opinion first thing out of your mouth
that's that's how we need to lead this
session
um so most important part uh deliver it
with with uh with power as well
so this is where a lot of thought
leaders also struggle is that okay you
finally get the perfect sentence out
but it's not delivered with any
enthusiasm or excitement and this is
from some top people as well who I know
are great speakers they're trying to
memorize that first sentence and then
when they say it the words come out
perfect but there's no emotional
commitment to it
you have to be emotionally connected to
the thing that you're saying as if
somebody is in front of you right now
and they're struggling with that very
thing and they need to hear from you I
know sometimes that's hard just talking
to a camera in studio and you're trying
to stress out about memorizing that
first line Etc but you your
um your stage presence really really
matters for anybody who's done speaking
you can get up on stage and say the
exact same words but if you don't have
stage presence you don't believe what
you're saying at the core of your being
you're not going to sway the audience
it's the exact same thing when you're
talking to a camera you're just talking
to you're talking to a bigger stage than
you would at any other stage but you
don't see them and so that makes it a
little more challenging so whether you
can call yourself out on it or if you've
got somebody on your team who's filming
with you who can say
hey uh that wasn't very good do it again
I remember when I recorded my audiobook
for for both built the server in your
one word I had two people in my ear my
producer who's looking at all the
technical stuff of like oh you know your
stomach rumbled or something
do that again and then I had another
producer who was in LA who was more
paying attention to the tone
like hey Evan you read it perfectly but
there was no energy there like okay
thank you man do it again and I'd pick
up from that line so the emotional
commitment like are you actually feeling
the words that you're saying as opposed
to just saying the words really really
really really matters once you get into
the teaching you'll be fine
I I very rarely meet somebody who signs
up for this program or other thought
leader experts trainers coaches I'm not
here to teach you how to teach for the
most part you guys do that great once
you get into the teaching you're fine
and you see that in the retention curves
like people are watching it's just that
beginning part and if we don't hook them
in at the beginning they're not going to
watch the rest of our teaching so
powerful opinion for a sentence second
sentence is context sentence like what
did you just say you just told me
something that doesn't make sense to me
you told me something that's challenging
one of my belief systems
so repeat it again in different words
make it make a little bit more sense and
then raise the stakes and raise the
stake says what happens to me if I don't
change this thing about myself if I
don't if I don't make this change by
watching this video this video is going
to teach you something it's going to
change my life I'm going to become a new
person at the end of this video right
that's the that's at least your
emotional state going in that's why
we're making this video to shift
somebody's belief system on something
that you know about
if I don't make that shift in this video
what happens
what happens to me if I stay stuck what
happens to me
your job as a thought leader is to give
perspective
it's not just this one-off little moment
that I'm struggling it's my entire life
and so that's your job is this one
little thing that people think they care
about they need to they need to have a
much broader view of how this is
impacting every area of their life and
if you fix that it becomes uh the
Cornerstone Habit to change everything
in your life right it's like oh my God I
thought I was just searching for a video
now I'm watching this person who's about
to change my whole life right so that's
that becomes your job
so powerful opinion context sentence
racist Stakes if you have to write those
down
those three sentences if you have to
record it 30 times until you get the
energy and the flow right it's worth it
because once you get through this and
you get into the teaching you'll be fine
I don't need you to do another take when
you're 20 minutes in and you're on point
number two of whatever your your
teaching is going to be but if you don't
nail the first three sentences film it
again and film it again and film it
again until until it you got the words
right and most importantly you got the
heart right
foreign
so uh here's Anna who uh a member of the
channel I don't I don't see her today
but Robert her husband is here on on the
stream so uh Robert can be taking notes
uh this is one of her videos trauma
bonding explained and YouTube has added
something relatively new for cards on
these um retention curves so if you ever
see an eye here you can click over it
and it'll show you what's going on so
she's got three intro continue segment
and dip uh intro is going to be here in
that blue section continue segment is
probably going to be here and then the
dip is going to be at the end it'll give
you some date on it we're not super
focused on these other two segments
we're focused on what happens at the
beginning so if you hover over the eye
on this one it says 81 percent of
viewers were still watching at the 30
second mark this is higher than typical
compared to your other other recent
videos nicely done hey hey good job good
job Robert you guys are doing it uh so
we look at this video right it's a 13
minute video trauma bonding explained
and I pulled okay well what is she doing
you know what what's happening why is it
so good so at the 118 Mark she's still
at 73 percent
118 into the video she's still at 73 so
this is a great video how does she start
the video
there's one kind of romantic
relationship that I wouldn't wish on
anyone and that's the kind that's been
made intense by a Chama Bond if you are
abused or neglected as a kid you've
probably been through it and I want to
help you make sure it never happens
again
right Robert's smiling hey she's doing a
good job she's doing a good job Robert
give her give her some props uh this is
great I mean it's four sentences instead
of three but it's still great so you
know we have a powerful opinion context
sentence raise the mistakes
the only thing I would uh swap out here
is probably
if it was one critique on here I would
not use the word probably at the
beginning of every video you don't want
to hedge this if you were abused or
neglected as a kid you've been through
this
and if there is a hedge then you address
it later but we don't address the Hedge
at the beginning
and that's where you know van we're here
to ask her well okay how many people
who've been neglected and abused as a
kid have not been through
this trauma
right there's probably some really low
percent
so don't hedge but everything else is
great and so she leads to the powerful
opinion she's hitting 73 at 118 into the
video uh YouTube's giving her props for
having such a great intro on it
and look how well the video is doing
right so this video is just over a month
old 40 whatever 43 days let's call it 20
000 views which is 5.5
000 more than usual
so the gray line is what a usual video
would do and here's how this video is
doing
so all in great job you know and then I
used to start her videos with with
something else it used to be hey man I'm
the crappy childhood fairy on and on and
on she switched it to powerful opinion
and it's working
if you like sharing the success stories
as well
now I also pulled an old video from the
channel that didn't have uh the the
powerful intro and this one is about
meditation so one I mean the thumbnail
isn't as good uh you know it's an older
video so Robert we can go back and work
on that one but look what happens at the
beginning
you know just tanks why well look at
what's happening on this video it's the
typical
uh logo with music copy childhood fairy
right and boom instantly tanks
right so now this also this video also
talks about meditation that's the
promise how to meditate twice a day
something
um The Meditation doesn't actually start
until here
so this is where we need to match the
thumbnail and the title and the
beginning of the video because people
are skipping ahead to get to here
because they don't want to see on any of
this intro or uh then Anna starts
talking about meditation Etc this is
what I mean this is a 24 minute video so
this is at least three four minutes into
the video
five minutes maybe
um before something actually happens
that delivers on the promise so when you
see a curve that drops this drastically
there's something wrong with our intro
right so now we can't go back and fix
this
um
but going forward it's a great example
of what is working and what is not
working for the channel
so I'm going to talk about
this up again when they're creating
their ad strategies so we we hopefully
know retargeting from our other
marketing efforts right somebody's hit
our landing page and then we hit them
with a Facebook ad or YouTube ad they've
you know face off them their cookie of
being on our page now we can retarget
them as much as possible we can do that
in YouTube as well for people who have
viewed a video but have not subscribed
to the channel
so often one of the biggest ways to win
in the short term is you create an ad
group
of people who have viewed videos on your
channel and you can go up to 540 days of
data
they viewed a video but they have not
subscribed yet to the channel
if they've already subscribed we don't
want to show them yeah they're already
our subscriber right unless we just care
about views we want to try to convert
people
so the next set of settings when you're
creating the campaign we've got
demographics this one really depends on
how much you know your demographics if
you know that you sell to middle-aged
women great you put that in there if you
know that you sell the teenage men great
you put that in there otherwise leave it
open and let YouTube find the best fit
for you the household income one is
interesting for buyers so if you're
selling something that's really high
ticket
you want to be targeting the upper 50 of
people for household income uh that's
again only specific you're trying to
Target buyers because if you want just
audience growth we want to Target
everybody and then here when you're
going to audiences this is where it can
start to get fun and we'll dive in a
little bit
uh on this session so you can pick who
you're going to Target
and you can pick who you're going to
exclude
so
this was this this is I just went to my
channel this is my one of my sub
channels this channel has 50 something
thousand subscribers on it so I tried to
pull something a little more close to
you guys
so not subscribed is 87 which is good
you want you're not subscribed to be in
the 75 to 90 range if you're talking
only to your subscribe people we've
talked about this on previous sessions
and your Channel's not growing because
you're only talking to people who know
who you are so so this is this is a good
number you can check out your own
numbers to see how well you're doing but
we want to be in the 75 to 90 range
and YouTube ads currently past 28 days
makes up eight percent of my views
so suggest is number one this is where
we want to be playing always right most
of the things that we've talked about in
previous sessions have been about how do
we get more suggested views that's where
you're going to get the organic growth
uh but there is a little bit of an ad
Budget on this channel and it's driven
eight percent of the views
so I've done two different audiences so
when you're in AdWords you go to your
audience manager
and you can create different audience
lists and you know for the veterans here
you know what I'm talking about for
newbies just go to audience manager and
and go to audience list and then click
plus you sync your YouTube channels and
I'm marketing to both my main Channel as
well as my top 10 rules Channel viewers
and what it will do is create a list and
you can select how many days the default
is 30 days
I stretch out to 540 so that's the max
so anybody who's watched a video in the
past 540 days stays on this list
so even if you're not into ads yet or
you're on the fence or you're thinking
about it it's worth just setting up this
audience because it starts tracking from
the day you set it up
so if I set it up today it gives me 30
days back plus everything forward
so even if you don't plan on running ads
until next year
right if you're gonna plan ads in one
year from today you'll at least have a
big audience of data where if you just
set up the audience in a year
you're starting from scratch
so at the very least you want to set up
viewers and subscribers for your Channel
the subscribers are helpful because you
can exclude them but also uh if you want
to Target them with pre-roll ads so if
you have a new book to sell new course
to sell new whatever else to sell you
can Target them not only on your channel
but if they come and watch an Evan
Carmichael video they can see your
pre-roll ad before it pitching your
thing and they already know who you are
where most of the ads like hi let me
introduce myself I am this expert as
opposed to they already know who you are
they've already subscribed to your
channel those are going to be much more
effective at converting to a sale
so step one is just creating those
audience lists
for your views
okay
then we're in our YouTube ads campaign
we can see that I added these two
audiences and I exclude that people who
already subscribe to the channel
so it's going to go to the people who
have viewed my videos but are not yet
subscribed
to my channel
this is one of the cheapest most
effective ways to start getting paid
Subs because you're targeting people
who've already watched one of your
videos now maybe you don't have millions
and millions of views that's fine
you can set caps and limits on how often
the ad will show up
but now your ad is going to be showing
up no matter where they go on YouTube
right again if they're following me
subscribe to me or they're just watching
some sports or some politics or whatever
on YouTube your video will still be
showing up as a suggested video because
they've watched another one of your
videos in the past 540 days
is all this making sense am I losing
anybody any questions yeah with shaking
heads okay
but again if if you need to pause
they're like wait I didn't understand
that slide pop it in the chat but we'll
also get the questions soon
so we're talking people who've watched
the video but I'm not yet subscribed and
showing them new content I like to put
in all the videos from the channel but
you can also pick select ones if you
want
so
this has shown what's happened in the
past 30 days I mean Canada so all these
are Canadian numbers so I spent not a
ton 700 bucks so let's call it 600 us
and I got 600 subscribers it's about a
dollar per subscriber I'm targeting the
Big Four
I don't care about just getting people
from anywhere to I don't care about
their vanity numbers enough on this
channel to go after them I want people
who are in the Big Four markets that I
could potentially sell to uh so it's
costing me a dollar to get a subscriber
it's pretty good if I was if I didn't
care about where they came from that'd
be a lot a lot a lot cheaper right here
it's costing me six cents so let's call
it five cents to get a view US
that would be under a cent if I was
going International the half a cent
point seven five cents to get a view
from people who viewed already one of my
videos
so this is where we want to be paying
attention
earn subscribers
uh you can see earned views so I've
gotten 11 000 views that I paid for and
it got me 7 300 views on top of it
so I paid for these and I got these for
free
that's pretty good targeting that's
almost you know whatever we want to call
that
65 percent of people who watch one who
watch the ad then go watch another video
on the channel
if you're seeing numbers like that
you've done a good job with the
targeting
and then 10 of them then roughly go on
to convert to become subscribers of the
channel
you can't optimize for this
so there's no rule that you can say
uh like sales this this is really
designed as a sales tool so it keeps
track of the click-through rate and the
cost per click and how many conversions
you get either just hitting your landing
page or hitting the hitting the
confirmation page you can tell Google
optimize for that you can't tell Google
optimize for earned subscribers
you just have to look at the report so
because it's an extra little step a lot
of people aren't doing it which creates
a lot of opportunity for you
Robert in the house for the ad video do
you always create a video as an ad or do
promote existing videos from your
Channel
the existing videos from the channel if
our goal is to convert them to
subscribers right
I've I've looked at a bunch of campaigns
where people were making videos and say
hey subscribe to my channel I'm going to
tell you how to do XYZ they make it an
ad
it just doesn't work as well as an
actual value
content
like think about what would you
subscribe to more
you know Casey hears from Jeff Jeff
Walker's team or Jeff comes on and
actually gives me value teaches me
something or Jeff comes on and says
subscribe to my channel it's gonna be
great I promise it's like people just
love the content a lot more uh you get
tested
but again you know my goal with all
these presentations to give you best
practices of what's actually working
right now so I would recommend you
actually doing
the videos on the channel either
specific videos and I'll share a screen
showing you what that looks like but
either specific videos that you want to
Target that audience or just all the
videos on your channel and let YouTube
decide which ones are having the best
impact
Jew says if you include the earned views
your effective cost per view is actually
three cents Canadian yeah Drew's doing
some some quick math uh yeah almost
right I got almost you know maybe maybe
three and a half cents Canadian you know
two and a half cents American right so
this this is just showing you how much
people actually are are connecting to
the content that you're putting up
so this is easy to get you know 11 000
views okay great
this are people then watching another
video on your channel that depends on
how not even how good the content is
because you guys have good content I'm
assuming the content's good when we've
talked a lot about your different
channels it's more about the audience
if you're targeting 13 year olds who
love Minecraft it doesn't matter how
good content you have
they're just not going to click and
they're not going to subscribe right if
they do is because they click the button
by accident so the target of the
audience becomes super important
so you can look at it on an ad group
level this is an ad group right just for
all of my top 10 videos and then you can
look at it on an individual video level
so what we'll do for this channel
because all of the content is pretty
much
the same it's similar
um we'll put all the videos in
and then we'll just sort by earned
subscribers and see which ones are doing
well now when it's under a hundred
subscribers gained it puts it in the
buckets
so
how many did this Bruce Lee one get us
in the past 30 days you know somewhere
between 61 to 80. as this gets over 100
it'll show you exact numbers
now we don't have a ton of data on
individual videos because
we max out you can have 300 videos in
one group
and we hit 300 and then we just slowly
the ones that get zero we pull out and
keep swapping new ones in so there's a
lot of data in here you can see this one
is AD number 110 ad number 104. we just
throw them all in and then let YouTube
decide to show the ones that are having
the biggest uptick
the reason why is because if if I was
picking
I wouldn't have picked any of these four
videos
you know if I was thinking okay what are
the ones that are going to pop off the
hardest for me on my top 10 Channel I
would have put I would have put Tony
Robbins you know I would have put Warren
Buffett I would have put Oprah Winfrey I
would have put some of the bigger names
but it's Bruce Lee the Dalai Lama
Jay-Z Michael Jordan I wouldn't have
picked these four and yet they're the
ones that are working the best
so you you could pick if you know the
targeting super well but otherwise if
it's if it's General to the category I
just throw all of them in
because they've already watched a video
on your channel now we're letting them
letting YouTube sort by whichever ones
are getting the the best results
YouTube's not going by earned
subscribers they're just basically
trying to optimize how many views you
can get for the budget so we're just
assuming that the more people view a
video the more likely they're going to
subscribe it's not
100 accurate right like this one
um
61 let's call this 70 subscribers for
for 900 views and this one got 400 views
for 10 subscribers so this one's
performing better in the past 30 days
right
um you could if you really want to go
video by video by video we just throw
them all in my assistant does it and
once we hit 300 usually once a week
she'll swap out the worst seven and then
pop seven new ones in
how to build an audience when most of
your keywords have heavy competition I
love the gym with you guys and help you
come up with the next videos to make us
think a lot of people struggle with what
do I make next and I'm making videos and
nobody's seeing them and I don't know
what topics to work on this is one of
the techniques that I often teach and
we've gone through it before but I like
to customize it and get some examples
from you guys to make it more personal
for Zane's a confidence coach so he's
going to come here and look at how to
have confidence if that's maybe a video
title that he would come up with and so
we use a video IQ plugin we've mentioned
this it allows you to see how many
subscribers each channel has and so this
one you know eight million views that's
cool but it has 16 million subscribers
on the channel so it's an
underperforming video so we look at this
one how to be confident in any situation
it's got 13 million views and 5 million
subscribers so this is one of the most
popular videos on his channel it's
helping him grow the channel and anytime
we have a higher sub count compared to
the Views most videos were
underperformed their sub count so most
videos we'll get if you've got 5 million
Subs we'll get less than 5 million views
whenever one does really well that means
it's a really good video so we want to
be taking on this video so then I asked
Stan in the office hey saying can you
make this video how to be confident
anything he's like yes perfect go make
that video and what what we'll often
find is the title that we we think of is
not the title that we end up going with
right we started with how to have
confidence
and we end up with how to be confident
in any situation
right and then part two is this is to go
look at their Channel and then see what
their other videos are and if we sort by
their most popular ones
you can see you know the how to have
confidence one
that's here oh or did he do it twice no
it's here it's weird it's how to radiate
confidence under pressure
it's weird that it's showing up in
search is something different than on
his channel he must be doing a split
test
anyway this is the video and this is
number three video
so then you can look at what other
videos have gotten more than five
million views and there's not that many
you know he's got 5.3 million subs and
this is what 6 12 you know 15 16 videos
have more than 5.3 million views
out of all the videos that he's done on
his channel right like this will just
keep scrolling and these are still
decent videos right but they're not the
ones that are really growing his channel
so then you just look at all these and I
you know five five common habits that
make people instantly dislike you can
Zane do that video maybe maybe not you
know liking you is it tied to confidence
sure but it may not be in his wheelhouse
how to how to avoid embarrassing
yourself in an argument maybe you know
the Zen talk about
arguments and negotiation embarrassment
you know it's it's on the verge
um but then something like this how to
turn awkwardness into confidence right
and then I asked and Zen can you make
that video it's like yes
like cool right and so you're just
basically looking for the videos that
are helping these videos are helping
grow
Charisma commands Channel
and even though it's you know it's
Charisma on command not confidence on
command but there's a lot of confidence
related videos
so the one of the biggest shifts I was
trying to get people to make at the
conference was the game is not searched
the game is suggested because so many of
the experts teach search but most of the
views don't happen in search most of the
views happen What YouTube recommends you
so the goal is to rank after other
people's videos so the SEO game is how
do I show up after other people's videos
not how do I show up for that search
term and so
to the topic of how to build an audience
when your keywords of heavy competition
it's not so much about the keywords
having heavy competition it's any videos
that are doing really well awesome we
want to be trying to rank after them
so for for you guys are here are there
any topics themes that you want to
either pop in the chat or you know it's
an intimate group you can unmike and
just we could Workshop it because I'd
love to be able to get
you leaving here with specific videos
you can go home and make
leadership skills
cool
so leadership skills
is it is a really broad topic right cool
so that's a good starting point so if
we're here we're on leadership skills
what do we got four tips improve
leadership skills with Brian Tracy
decent you know 649 versus 1.3 it's okay
10 leadership skills every leader should
have it's okay
1.6 versus 34. it's okay here's
something but Tony Robbins on the
psychology and skills of exceptional
leaders probably not one that you're
going to make unless you're going to
dissect Tony Robbins but not as good
this is actually this is actually rough
a lot of these are rough so far
here's one though how to be a great
leader the seven great leadership traits
1.3 million views off of 70 subscribers
or 70 000 subscribers
could you come up with seven great
leadership traits Terry
absolutely yeah so this is this is this
is a good one to make but overall this
is it also shows you how
how difficult it might be or how good a
topic is right so these people all have
a lot of subscribers actually this one
this one doesn't with the 1000 but a lot
of these videos they're getting a lot
fewer views and subscribers so it could
also lead us to think what else could we
call it instead of calling it leadership
skills what else could we call it
and by changing up one of those words we
might find a better topic so this is
this is this is a little bit below
average as a as a as a term but there
are still some gems in here you know
like this one how to be a great leader
seven great leadership trade this is the
best one on here
um
all of these are underperforming
unless it's specific right so Seth God
and even here garyvee talking leadership
skills 46 000 views but he's got three
million subscribers
five crucial tips on leadership for
first-time managers
is that is that in the Wheelhouse Terry
or is that that's a good one I mean
because five crucial uh tips on
leadership for first-time managers I
mean the number one thing would be
developmental counseling so I mean I
have ideas in which I can talk about on
that
it's more than this so I mean cry five
if it was just five crucial leadership
five crucial tips on leadership cool but
for first time managers does that fit
into who you're trying to reach
it could I mean once again it's it's a
matter of of who I want to reach and and
if I'm wanting to reach first-time
managers yeah it'd be a good one
cool so this video really performed well
for him 18 000 Subs 238 000 views and
especially if you're a smaller Channel
looking at smaller channels right can
really help so
18 000 is not is not a it's not a tiny
Channel but it's not a giant Channel
either for the Charisma command it's got
five million subscribers
um so that's interesting body language
of leaders
is interesting I don't know if you go
that route or not Terry but I have I've
talked about things like for example how
the eyebrows is the most expressive body
part so I I do talk about some elements
of body language
so this is where it could get really
cool it's like hey you look at Vanessa
Fernandez this is the she's shown up a
couple times now right there's this
video but then there was this video
underneath so this got 2.1 this got 360
000. I believe she was up higher
somewhere here
here 338 000. so when she's just talking
about leadership skills it's really
underperforming compared to talking
about the body language of leaders
about that
yeah and this is what she's known for
but it's also you know it's what people
are searching for what they're
connecting with which is getting a lot
of traction on so could you provide your
perspective on the body language of
leaders and the goal becomes let's try
to show up after Vanessa van Edwards oh
yeah I probably have about seven to ten
things of body language I could talk
about for sure
cool cool and so that's that's the
starting point right so we've we've
we've got
one video here second video here and
there was a third video
on this one right so these are so we've
got three video ideas that you can make
cool next is to look at all their
channels and see what other videos
they've got and if there's any fit
before even moving away so like already
leadership skills may not be the best
the best uh term because a lot of these
are underperforming so we can try on
another term that might give us a lot
more fruit but we've already got three
videos that we can use
right uh okay so next we go and look at
those channels you know
learning read the find was one what was
the other two this one burned burned
girop wow I probably butchered that name
uh and then Vanessa van Edwards okay and
then same thing
and the more
they're related to you the more options
it will be and there may not be anything
that you can pull from but you just sort
each one
and this gives us a starting point for
ideas six signs she wants you
okay Terry are we making that all right
that was a good laugh though I like that
one
we're probably not making that video but
you never know so 10 tricks to get her
to like you okay you know and a lot of
these look like book reviews uh so this
could be you know where Pablo comes in
you know with his book reviews and the
videos that he likes he likes doing it
um but yeah so there may not be a lot
here that we can pull from but a lot of
these videos have done well
but could Terry take that six signs she
wants you
and and as soon they come in it says
um women women loves a man who's a
leader and then
transition on his his three or four ways
to become the leader and what you you
follow me yeah so so there's two things
to that the first is
how ethical does like how how connected
does Terry feel to the message so it's
still got to be hard first and then you
wrap your brain around it right so if
it's just a strategy then if it's too
much of a stretch outside what you do
don't do it just because it's a good
topic okay otherwise you're going to end
up hating your channel and hating the
work that you're doing because you're
you're stretching like could you apply
leadership to anything yes can you play
confidence to anything yes of course
right but is that what you if Terry then
just goes and makes all of these kinds
of videos is he losing his soul
you know because it's just not fun to
make and the second part of that is are
you bringing in the right people so
ultimately what does Terry want to sell
you know if he if he wants to sell
leadership training and coaching
services for example making a video six
signs she wants you is is probably
targeting you know 13 14 16 18 22 year
old guys and uh they're probably not
going to be anywhere close to buying so
unless he's playing a really long game
and this is like a 15-year play for
Terry and just really thinking ahead of
the curve then it's probably not the
best fit and just move on to other
topics
this is a fun topic this is something
that I obsess over how do we get our one
minute audience retention it's it's a
super geeky topic uh of all the things
that um
that I
try to teach when I'm doing
presentations uh this is the only thing
that I get technical with the audience
retention curve the audience retention
curve the audience retention curve like
remember this thing pay attention to it
look at your data because it's easy to
get lost in YouTube data but this one is
super super important understand that
YouTube's goal is to keep you on YouTube
right that's their goal so the more
you're keeping people on YouTube the
more they're going to promote your
videos and so many people focus on
the entire video which is important but
what often happens is if you get the
first minute down really well and you're
keeping people for for that attention
they'll watch the rest of the video If
you go look at most of your curves you
you'll see it's mostly flat or just
slowly sloping down but that first
minute is where we tend to lose people
so people are often shocked if you go
look at your own stats people are often
shocked at how poorly their videos are
doing in that first minute so today
that's what we are talking about let me
share my screen boom specific strategies
that boost viewer retention who I'm
excited okay let's dive in so the goal
the goal is 70 at one minute this is uh
this is a really hard number to hit
especially consistently nobody hits this
number consistently not not inside
thought leadership I don't do it nobody
that I've looked at does it
um
it's really really really really hard
and I've looked at everybody's Channel
at least the big Channel since I thought
leadership but it's still the goal it's
still that elusive here's what we're
working towards and this curve that's
the honest attention curve you'll see
this on every single video this is free
inside YouTube Studio product uh you can
get lost again in data but this one is
super super important and it'll show you
basically where people are falling off
so wherever you know here whatever
happened here that sucks then that was
good then that sucks and then that
sucked at the end and then these little
Peaks here this is what we're going to
share to social content right we've
talked about this in the past but uh
just quick refresh
this slide is one of you guys may have
seen in the past one minute retention
this video we did had 73 at one minute
has almost three million views on the
channel and this is what a typical Curve
will look like right it should be slowly
just declining over time and it's this
part that we're really trying to
optimize in this first minute trying to
make sure that we're keeping it not that
big a slump so you'll always get this
you'll always get this little drop here
at the beginning the key is not making
that drop and losing 40 of our audience
which happens to a lot a lot a lot a lot
a lot of channels
so here's something that we haven't
talked about yet that I wanted to just
bring up on your radar tubebuddy has a
tool that I requested uh and help them
build called the retention analyzer now
it's a little buggy and they don't
update it very often because they
basically made it for me and some of the
people who like using it
um but it's not part of their core thing
that like everybody's using it for but
if you are using tubebuddy for split
testing right now
tubebuddy is a tool that we use we've
done over ten thousand split tests on
the channel thumbnails titles Etc
if you're on that program you're on that
package I think that's 50 bucks a month
something like that it's not it's not
crazy expensive they have something
built in here as well called retention
analyzer
so if you go to your tubebuddy you click
on data and insights on the left and
then scroll down to retention analyzer
it'll pull up your most recent it's not
all it says all videos it's not it's
going to be your most recent I think 50
videos and then you can sort by
retention at various time stamps so I'd
say with sort by the one minute Mark and
see where you're at and you can just get
a sense of how well you're doing which
videos are performing well which videos
aren't uh just to give you a sense you
know instead of having to Go videos one
by one by one by one by one this will
help you give get an over overall sense
and see where you're doing well and
which videos uh are not doing so well
and we need to make a few adjustments to
help your channel grow so I would
definitely check that out if you're if
you're on the package for the split
testing you're already paying for this
anyway so you might as well take a look
and see which videos are performing well
and where there's some room for
improvement okay so today we're going to
talk about a lot of the dues but before
that I want to talk talk about some of
the don't do so this is the things you
want to avoid when you're starting your
video okay these will these will destroy
your audience retention curve
intros hi I'm Evan and I XYZ right no
intros live stream welcomes are the
worst you know a live stream
the first couple minutes usually really
really really suck on the live stream
you're welcoming people you're saying hi
you're asking about their day that's
great for a live stream environment but
not great for a YouTube video again
we're we're trying to assume that people
who are watching our videos don't know
who we are that's our target audience
we're not talking to our subscribers
we're talking to our non-subscribers
this is the first time they're seeing
you so we want to hit them with
something that's going to be really
powerful don't do a Sizzle reel
you getting out of your car looking
fancy or on stage looking like a special
person like none of that stuff really
brings in a lot of attention uh call to
actions we don't want call to actions at
the beginning because we lose people
you'll see a big drop in your honest
attention curve and then Audio Only
Audio Only is really hard we're I'm
working on a couple strategies actually
with some podcasters like how do I turn
my podcast into a YouTube video when I
don't have video when it's just an audio
stream and every time I've seen it it's
really tanked but if you can make it
visually appealing I think there's a
case I think there just hasn't been a
lot of innovation on the podcast inside
for how you can play with visuals so
these are all the don't Do's don't do
any of these things and if you're
looking at your data and you're seeing
that you're you're at you know 40
retention at one minute you're probably
doing one or multiple of these and it's
not helping your videos grow
okay so we just finished uh
a breakdown of 990 of our videos this
just happened on Tuesday so what they
say Thursday so two days ago I haven't
even gone through all the data myself
yet but uh I had one of my guy my I have
a full-time data analyst on my team and
that's what he does is goes and looks
store data and gives us suggestions on
what's working what's not working and he
compiled this giant spreadsheet of of
which videos are popping hard you know
we're at 78 retention at one minute in
which ones are underperforming and so
I'm going to share with you some of the
insights that we found today which I'm
excited because I didn't even know some
of these things until Tuesday
um having a full-time data analyst
really really helps
uh so I'm excited let's dive in and look
at some of the some of the data Okay so
that first minute again our goal is to
capture attention so multiple camera
angles we found really really has been
helping and this is some of the stuff
that I used to do that I haven't done as
much it's it's shocking when you look at
your data you might find oh something I
was doing back in 2019 is actually
outperforming what I'm doing right now
and all of these numbers are for the
past 90 days on my channel so it's not
lifetime of video this worked I've been
around for 12 years or something so it's
not like this worked back in 2014 and it
doesn't work anymore all the stats is
basically the last 90 days so multiple
camera angles we did four transitions in
the first 15 seconds and that helped
lead to 78 at one minute
okay getting outside
switching up the background having some
color
again this one four transitions in 18
seconds 70 at one minute
so I'm seriously looking at okay what
what could we do besides just using I
love my studio but besides just using
the studio what else could we use where
else could we go now some of this
requires more editing this one is pretty
simple this one even if you're doing it
yourself you could just do different
camera angles
for the intro this is only for the first
minute don't worry about making it
highly produced
um I
value editing but I think ultimately
it's going to be your capabilities to
pull out great information it's going to
carry the day but in that first minute
especially the editing can can make a
difference to hook somebody's attention
so you could do this even if you're
filming on your own but if you have
somebody as a camera operator helping
you you can move the side move around
just have different angles and again
just getting outside if you can if it's
warm we got summer you know right here
so can you do anything outside uh to
just shake up the background just to
make it a little more interesting a
little more appealing
um one Hack That Billie Jean loves doing
for his ads if you don't know Billie
Jean he's one of the the experts on on
advertisements so YouTube ads Facebook
ads Etc is go look up in your city what
are the top places that people like to
go to
and then try to film there
so it takes more time uh it takes more
budget it takes it takes a team to maybe
help you but if there's an interesting
background so I'm in Toronto there's you
know the CN tower there's Niagara Falls
there's you know different places but if
you look at the top places people like
to visit and then that happens to be in
your background that could help just get
people interested at the beginning
Fast Cuts so
here's an example where we did 10
transitions in 21 seconds
where we're doing a preview of things to
come and this is something that after
looking at the data on this we're going
to be playing with it instead of longer
clips
doing coming up leading with shorter
Clips but more of them as opposed to
longer more in-depth Clips really that
first minute is people are justifying
their time with you
I don't know who you are I like the
topic do I want to watch this video you
know it's like people will skim an
article before they read it that's
what's happening right now so if you can
give them a chance to skim the video
before they watch it you can hook them
in so this is something when we plan a
lot more with uh we're after seeing this
I just instructed my team hey I want our
next two weeks of videos on the top 10
Channel I want to be doing 10 cuts for
each one and let's see if we can play
this out so think about your own videos
think about your own content you don't
have to have 10 rules
but how can you take some of the
Highlight moments and instead of just
one or two highlight moments go for five
six seven eight highlight moments that
are in more in Rapid succession to say
okay there's a lot there's a lot of meat
coming up in this video
I want to watch it so this this was
really mind-blowing for me this was some
experiment we did I don't know back in
2016 just as a as a one-off and never
went back to it for whatever reason it's
like wait a minute that actually worked
let's go back and look at it and you
know when you have 10 000 videos like I
do on my channel uh there's a lot of
data to report to to get some
interesting information so super fast
Cuts I would definitely play with some
of these for your videos if you want to
see this full video as well as trained
live with me twice a month to blow up
your brand join the brand Linux training
program there's a link to join right
there next to me continue to believe
I'll see you there